chaque au couple a ses particularités
est ce qu'il faut mais on en est à avoir
une approche générale d'infidélité oui
si la clé je sais pas moi dire ça veut
dire le cubisme en fait c'est pas la
réussite mais c'est l'épanouissement du
lait mais non mon avis si on te trompe
et c'est bien ce que tu faisais pas bien
l'amour sexton c'est tout tu seras non
on va vous parler dans un instant on
peut s'engueuler où on va on va d'abord
en parler comment ça s'est passé vous
avez découvert
si vous aviez vous étiez en même temps
comment j'étais avec lui depuis combien
de temps
trois en trois ans donc et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais il m'a trompé on vous
l'avez appris il s'est affiché avec des
photos que j'ai découvert à travers des
amis oui et on a du coup fait une petite
technique pour le faire sortir et
rentrer tout déglingué à l'intérieur
d'accord ou simplement vous avez été
blessé
oui beaucoup énormément mais j'ai très
vite compris que coller la faute ne
venait pas demain en fait justement
c'est pas moi qui n'ai pas combler un de
ses besoins
c'est lui qui manque de confiance en lui
c'est lui qui a besoin de d'aller voir
ailleurs pour se prouver quelque chose
c'est d'un staff personnel j'ai l'âge et
excuse pas tu me coupe pas dans ce cas
faut pas sondages
au passage je vous attrape avec elle la
demi-heure vous quand même non
la valeur des permis à rémy % avec café
de temps arrêtez arrêtez ça on va pas
rentrer là c'est très joli tout ça se
lâcher sur les yeux vous qu au manque de
confiance en son jeu deviendra un fidèle
waura des valeurs très jolie pas deux
mais bien sûr si tu es une femme
découpée comprend rien de ce que vous
dites là donc ça sert à rien n'est pas
le sien fait pareil est ce que je
voulais dire c'était pas méchant ce que
je voulais dire mais dans le mobile
en fait c et c est que l'un des fils du
régime que tu l'aimés l'atome est allé
voir ailleurs parce que t'es trop mais
c'est pas ça l'amour c'est pas la classe
et de l'autre ça j'ai l'amour c'est
accepter que l'autre puisse s'amuser
c'est ça l'amour mais la position
alors alors ne parlez pas de réponse je
vous sortir demain